what's up you guys it's joelle and for
the next week i'm going to attempt to
eat like the
incredibly talented and super sweet
korean girl group
twice twice has nine wonderful members
so in an attempt to squeeze all of this
into one week
i'm gonna be recreating at least two of
each member's
favorite dishes and see by the end of
the week whose dishes i thought were the
most delicious
i am so excited so ready to feel special
so
let's get on into it so we're starting
the week off with gio who
is twice's fearless leader she is a main
vocalist for the group and is definitely
the team mom
jihyo actually trained at jyp their
entertainment company for
over 10 years which makes her the twice
member with the longest tenure at jyp
she likes to eat healthy and exercise so
i'm starting out the day with a yogurt
smoothie which is apparently one of her
favorites
honestly i feel like i put so much
yogurt in this that it's kind of like a
milkshake so i'm really excited about
starting my day with this
so good you just can't go wrong with a
good berry smoothie i am
so excited for lunch i've read that
another one of juha's favorites is
meat i decided to make myself some
bulgogi it is so easy to go to the
korean grocery store and get either
pre-made marinades or just pre-marinated
meats so you already know
that's what i did today and i'm so
excited to eat of course you gotta wrap
your meat and your some your
leaves i'm gonna shove it in there you
know
one thing i find really interesting
about how jiho became the leader of
twice is that she was actually
decided on by popular vote of the other
members i think it's really telling of
how much
all the other girls respect jiho that
they asked for her
to lead the group for dinner i'm having
one of nyan's favorites
diane is an incredible all-around member
of twice as a dancer
a singer off in the center of a lot of
videos and formations
but she also has a really interesting
career trajectory she was actually
scouted by jyp as
a really young kid but her mom didn't
want her to become a trainee so young so
years later she goes back in auditions
for jyp and makes it and convinces her
mom to let her train
one of her favorites is apparently some
sushi so i got some salmon sushi because
apparently that is
the only type of sushi that she will eat
this honestly looks
so good oh yeah baby
even though i personally love all types
of sushi honestly we're gonna pick one i
think salmon is a
fantastic choice anyways before we end
today i want to end it off with
a twice fun fact twice was formed by jyp
entertainment under the reality
competition show called 16.
through the show there are supposed to
only be seven members in the final group
but at the end of the show jyp added
momo because of her dancing skills and
chewie was added by popular vote thanks
to the audience
good morning and today we're starting
off the day with another meal for nyan
she apparently really enjoys the flavor
of grapefruit so i'll just keep things
simple keep it fresh with a grapefruit
for breakfast
in addition i know many of the girls of
twice talk about how they drink coffee
all the time especially iced americanos
so to be accurate honestly i should
probably just have a nice americana like
every day this week really doing these
eating like kpop stars
videos has put me on to ice americanos i
never drank them before
but they're so good i love espresso so
much
okay for lunch today i'm having a
favorite of chunyuns jungyeon is often
described as like the girl crush member
of the group
if you watch any videos of her you'll
understand why she's so effortlessly
cool
and beautiful and just feels so powerful
she's the main vocalist for the group
but has apparently said that if she
weren't an idol she would go into
modeling
and apparently one of her food favorites
is tapuki twice has actually invented
their own replicate recipe which is just
taki with ramen
in one of their shows they made a recipe
from scratch and had chongyong's dad try
to recreate it
since he's actually a well-known korean
chef i was a little skeptical when i saw
this recipe they were throwing in all
kinds of crazy things
like honey rice cakes marinara sauce but
also things that i've never used before
like
quail eggs and they even put some yogurt
in there which is probably the part that
i was
most concerned about unfortunately my
grocery store was out of honey rice
cakes but other than that i tried to
follow the recipe
to a tea a tt okay y'all i'm scared i'm
not
gonna lie i was sort of shocked when
twice seemed to devour their dish and
loved it in the show but i guess if they
designed the recipe themselves
it must be according to their taste and
you can't really go wrong with ramen
noodles
wow there's so many different flavors
going on right now it has like
the kind of sweetness from the ketchup
and the marinara sauce
it's just fascinating honestly i don't
hate it just wash it all down i actually
have
nyan's go-to milk tea order apparently
she said when she wants something
refreshing but not too heavy
she'll get a classic milk tea but with
no boba and 50
sweet having something creamy and sweet
when you're eating spicy food for some
reason
is so satisfying micah's going to react
so it's good it's good you like it
nice dinner tonight i'm very excited to
try it's another one of jungyeon's
apparent
favorites and it is let me try to say
this right
and it is spicy sea wilk with noodles
and i was a little intimidated because
i've never actually had
this dish before so i'm really excited
to try and even though it might sound a
little strange to eat sea snails
let's just all remember escargot is a
delicacy okay
this honestly smells bomb and i love
cold spicy noodles let's take a bite
the seasoning of this is so good it does
have a cake though here's my little
seawell
it really just tastes like clam and to
end the day today's twice fact is that
pre-debut many of the members appeared
in ads and music videos for other idols
chaeyoung and chewie were in miss a's
video for only you and changyong
nyan dahyun and sana all appeared in
different videos from jyp's boy group
got7
we are starting today with a mina
classic mina is an incredible vocalist
and dancer for the group she's also the
only member to be born in the u.s
but she was raised in japan prior to
joining the group she apparently studied
ballet for like
11 years and had the shortest tenure at
jyp
as a trainee i saw an interview where
she said that one of her favorite foods
to eat is actually
ketchup growing up she would have
ketchup with a lot of different foods
especially
eggs so that is what i'm having for
breakfast i tried to make the ketchup in
the shape of an
m but it came out too fast so i messed
up eggs and ketchup is such a classic
combo
so today's lunch is actually inspired by
miss momo
who is a main dancer some vocalist and
rapper for the group
all around so talented she is also from
japan and apparently
started dancing at the age of three
she's apparently also a pretty big cook
so she shared some photos of
dishes that she'd cooked online and one
of them was pudejige which is what i'm
making today
it is korean army stew and apparently
was popularized in korea after the
korean war in the
50s it was made up of pretty much a
bunch of army surplus foods with a bunch
of preservatives things like spam
ramen noodles gochujang things that keep
really well
and was so delicious that it kind of
became a like mainstay
in korean cuisine even now the soup base
of this is very very flavorful
salty and spicy everything just like
soaks into all the foods you're eating
so good
while i'm enjoying my lunch i figure
i'll share today's twice fact
while most k-pop groups often release
japanese or english versions of their
songs
twice actually releases full thai
versions of many of their albums
already so it couldn't be a day of
eating like twice's momo without what
dish
that's right y'all chokbar and that is
braised
pig's feet you boil these bones for
literally
two hours in a medley of spices
and it turns super super tender and momo
freaking loves this dish it's almost
like a meme now so i had to try to make
it oh my gosh that is like the most
tender meat i've ever had
momo is so enthusiastic about how much
she likes this i
saw this hilarious variety show segment
where she was asked to do a dance
with a piece of jackpot like she had a
braised pig's foot and she did a dance
complete with a one-handed cartwheel and
meat was
flying everywhere it was hilarious
that's what i knew i was like you know i
gotta try to make this recipe for this
video
so to end today i figured with all the
excellent dancers and twice
momo mina nyan chewie pretty much all of
them though
i thought it'd be fun for my sister and
i to try to learn one of their dances
and
the feel special dance definitely went
viral right when it came out
and i never learned it so i figured now
would be a good time to try
sadly again cannot show you with the
music dude copyright but we love some
twice choreo even over
that nice royalty-free music good
morning and today's breakfast is
inspired by
sweet sweet sauna sauna is a vocalist
from osaka japan
apparently she's a little on the shire
side which blows my mind because she's
such an incredible performer
i saw this photo of sana and tahia
enjoying some waffles that looked
scrumptious but from the photo they
weren't just regular waffles they looked
like league waffles which are a
different kind of waffle that actually
uses
yeast in the dough and you add something
called pearl sugar which i didn't have i
just may do with some lump sugar when
you
put it in the waffle iron it melts and
caramelizes so it has this really
delicious crispy outside
and soft and fluffy inside actually this
is a very decadent breakfast
it's really crispy and caramelized it
just goes with the whipped cream and the
fruit so well
i love twice's group dynamic in a lot of
interviews they
definitely roast each other but they're
also super supportive in a recent
buzzfeed interview actually when asked
who was the most likely to cook for
everybody
obviously everyone pointed to momo miss
chef but mo
actually pointed to meena because when
they lived together mina made momo some
really delicious hawaiian poke
if you've never had poke it is a
hawaiian dish normally consisting of cut
up raw fish with a little bit of
seasoning
i unfortunately had to buy my poke i
feel like it's good to be aware that
this is not how poke is traditionally
eaten normally is just a fish
itself maybe with some rice not with all
of these fixings where this is basically
like
a sashimi salad that's not to say that
this isn't delicious but i'm just pretty
sure
that meena made momo a much more
traditional version of poke
okay for dinner tonight i had to make
cheese kim pop to honor
sana one of the most iconic clips of
sana is when she's
playing telephone for a korean variety
show and the word is
cheese kim pop just the way she said it
has been memed and clipped
so many times all over the internet
admittedly i was a little perplexed when
i first saw this clip because it felt so
random
but truly for me it was a twinkle in
santa's eye when she gets the word
cheese kim puff right that made me just
fall in love with her
even more kim pop is literally just rice
wrapping seaweed with
whatever you want in it so obviously i
included some mozzarella cheese instead
of regular rice i made kimchi fried rice
i'm not gonna lie all i am
very proud of how this turned out this
is actually my first time
hand rolling kim pop since i was a kid
and would do it maybe with my grandma
but this is my first time doing it on my
own
it's trying to show y'all i'm just gonna
wipe that out real quick yummy
i will say the taste of the mozzarella
and the kimchi pokemop really go well
together
i also know some of you might be
confused as to why a video of a girl
saying cheese kim pop on a variety show
has the power to garner like millions
and millions of views uh and that would
go back to something that koreans call
egg yo
which is a quality of cuteness
that i feel like has the level of draw
or desirability that
maybe americans would consider hotness
or beauty
but anyways before we go today's twice
fact is that twice has actually been
featured in questions on school exams in
both taiwan
and korea so today's breakfast is
inspired by tahiana she
is a literal ray of sunshine and is one
of the rappers it's a vocalist for the
group
and she loves sweets particularly
chocolate and she says that one of her
favorite drinks is chocolate milk so
that's what i'm having for breakfast but
i couldn't just have chocolate milk so
i'm also having a little korean pastry
on the side
there's something so comforting about
chocolate milk that just reminds me of
childhood so good i know i've already
eaten noodles a lot this challenge but
apparently ramen is one of these staples
for the girls of twice
and they eat it a ton especially because
they're on the road often and it's super
quick easy and
obviously delicious i also chose ramen
for times lunch
specifically because there was an
interview where chaeyoung was asked
if taeyeon was a food what would she be
and she said
ramen which makes sense because taiyon
is so playful and bubbly
and i feel like everyone likes her just
like everyone likes ramen
so much sodium so satisfying also for
anyone who wants to get a sense of
tahan's
very outgoing personality you can see
that she actually went
viral prior to debuting with twice for a
dance that's known as the eagle dance
that she did as she was leading dance in
church
she was literally like so dinner tonight
is inspired by chaeyoung
she is a main rapper and sub vocalist
for the group she's also
extremely fashionable and really
artistic where she said that if you
weren't an idol right now she would have
actually tried to go to art school which
is really cool
she says that one of her favorite foods
is fruits and veggies we love a healthy
queen and i saw and i think what was a v
live her having this really delicious
looking arugula salad with tomatoes
so that's what i decided to have for
dinner tonight i'm really excited to eat
this because honestly i've eaten
very few vegetables this week so this is
very refreshing
anyways before i go today's twice fact
is that twice's debut video
like uh was their first to hit 100
million views on youtube
it hit the milestone in november 2016
after one year
and 23 days exactly so it is quite late
now but another aspect
of twice's routine that i thought i'd
try to replicate is their skin
care chaeyoung and nyon did a v live
showing their
nighttime getting unready routine i
personally really appreciated that they
would share this with their fans because
i feel like it's kind of rare to see
kpop idols
without perfect makeup on and it just
felt so casual and down to earth like
we're out of sleep over taking off our
makeup altogether
and you already know i was taking
furious notes to figure out how they get
that incredible glass skin
in the live nyan and chaeyoung used
three cleansers starting with a makeup
remover wipe
a foam cleanser and an oil cleanser to
get all that stage makeup off
chiang used some essence and then they
used a classic korean sheet mask which
nyon says she uses literally every day
and they ended it off with some lip balm
night cream and eye cream
i can't believe it is the last day of
our challenge but we're kicking off
today
with a chewy breakfast chewy is the
maknae of the group aka the youngest
member
she's also the only member from taiwan
she is an incredible vocalist and dancer
and has even inspired a skateboarding
mobile game which i sadly couldn't
download because they don't offer it for
iphone
she is known for loving bread and
pastries so of course i had to have
some bread in my breakfast additionally
i saw in a recent interview that on a
trip to thailand she really enjoyed this
drink called tang mopan it is a super
refreshing watermelon smoothie so that's
what i decided to pair my pastry with
it is so refreshing and light this
honestly reminds me of like a tropical
cocktail that you might get
but it's literally like 9 a.m right now
so obviously i'm having mine
alcohol free i'm already so hungry for
lunch and i'm really excited
making another favorite that chewie has
mentioned in an interview and that is
gonde namup which people sometimes call
korean thistle with rice it apparently
was commonly eaten in buddhist temples
it's supposed to be really good for you
i'm just having mine with a bunch of
veggies and panchon kimchi all that good
stuff
it's like a really yummy kind of earthy
flavor i know i often make a lot of meat
dishes
this is an excellent vegan option that i
would highly highly recommend
in addition to eating healthy most of
the time chaeyoung also says that she
really likes gummies i think a lot of
the girls in twice actually have said
that they like gummies
asian snacks are the best and my sister
here is a gummy fiend
so figured we would try some of these
different gummies we eat these all the
time
we love some fettuccine these are
another classic
individually wrapped pieces solid
i'm trying a little strawberry gummy
it's so cute
mango it really does taste like the
fruit i thought these looked really cute
also they're little peach gummies a
little booty peach it has good texture
i think the fettuccine is my favorite so
i think i have to agree
glad we got to try one of twice's guilty
pleasures if you want to partake in some
asian gummies as well
this stuff's really good it is our last
meal of eating like twice so i thought
it ended off with a meal that i know all
the girls
enjoy together and that is chapchae
which is just stir-fried sweet potato
noodles with veggies and normally some
beef i made mine vegetarian though and
goguma matang which is candied sweet
potato i
unfortunately made the rookie mistake of
buying american sweet potatoes instead
of the korean goguma sweet potato
which is white rather than orange but
when you're frying and candying a sweet
potato i feel like it tastes good either
way in a recent interview i watched
twice was talking about how they often
would order food together and eat
together which makes sense because
they're constantly traveling
training on the road and i think it's
really sweet that they share so many
meals honestly it's like having
a second family because they spend so
much of their time together
so obviously i'm starting out with the
chapter which is the savory dish that i
made
seasoning with the soy sauce and sugar
is so
easy so definitely an a1 dish if you're
new to cooking it's kind of hard to mess
up and of course before we move on to
dessert have to finish off with my final
twice fact and that is that the official
fandom name
once was announced on november 4th 2015
through their official instagram account
the group said if you love us even once
we will repay your love with twice our
love we will work hard so you can look
at us once
and fall in love with twice let's be
together until the end
gotta finish off the video with some
dessert
that crunch the crystallization is so
good
and honestly y'all as i'm looking back
on this week we made
so many delicious meals but i have to
say i think if you're going to make
one dish from this week i would
recommend momo's
choc par just the complexity of the
seasonings are so delicious
and if you're vegan or vegetarian i
definitely would recommend just trying
that little marinade with all the
seasonings
and rather than raising pig's feet
definitely some potatoes some veggies
all that good stuff would taste
delicious in it over some rice i had so
much fun recreating all of these twice
foods this week i hope you learned a
little bit more about twice as well as
about korean culture and if there's
anyone you'd like me to eat like next
let me know in the comments down below
and i'll see you in the next one bye
[Music]
you